what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series before we
break down the most powerful characters
in comics and you know sometimes i look
at the characters we've covered and i'll
just be shocked when i notice characters
that i can't believe we haven't covered
already and that happened this week when
i noticed that we never covered dr
manhattan in beyond omega levels so we
need to change that so dr manhattan was
created by alan moore and dave gibbons
and first appeared in watchmen number
one in 1986. now like the rest of the
watchmen characters dr manhattan was
based on a character from charlton
comics in this case dr manhattan was
based in part on captain adam a
character who would later make his way
to dc comics along with several other
charlton characters and a character we
have covered on beyond omega level
before if you want to check that out now
ultimately both moore and dc editorial
decided it'd be better to use original
characters instead of trout and
characters and so the watchmen were born
now dr manhattan's real name is john
osterman who was born in 1929 and whose
father was a watchmaker which is also
what jon plans to become but when the
u.s drops the first atomic bomb on
hiroshima japan at the end of world war
ii jon's father pushes him towards a
career in nuclear physics and so john
gets a phd from princeton and begins a
career in nuclear physics where he meets
a woman named janie slater who he
basically falls in love with now one
fateful day john ends up leaving his
watch inside the test chamber of an
experiment that he's working on and goes
back in to get it john's locked in the
chamber and the experiment engages which
results in john seemingly being
disintegrated now over the next few
months however john's body reforms
itself and eventually he reappears fully
intact but looking quite different with
a glowing blue body and a set of
superpowers now one of the questions you
guys are probably asking here is rob how
does a person
learn things like like nuclear physics
how does a person become that smart well
i'll tell you exactly how you know it's
been a little while it's been a little
while i know you guys know it's coming
the way you learn stuff like that is
using skillshare yes ladies and
gentlemen this video is sponsored by
skillshare now i'm not aware of any
classes that will teach you how to
become a nuclear physicist but i am
aware of a class by a guy named
nathaniel drew
which is called how to speak confidently
on camera a guide for content creators
and this is one that was really really
impactful for me i mean it's one of
those things to kind of keep in mind
that as a content creator your skills
are ever changing and ever learning and
you're constantly progressing and there
are times when those skills become a
little bit rusty and a lot of you all
are also looking to become content
creators yourself this course in
particular was great because i know that
public speaking is like the number one
fear of virtually everybody in the world
but it's also learning how to become
confident when you talk on camera it is
a little weird at first you're literally
talking to a machine that's recording
your face and your voice and it's not an
actual person what this course does is
teach you how to engage with the camera
as if you're talking to a person so that
when you're someone like me and you're
just in front of a microphone or in
front of a camera that you can speak
with confidence and you don't sound kind
of like i mean hey what's going on guys
my name's rob and you don't sound unsure
of yourself so the first 1 000 of my
viewers to sign up through my link in
the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare so that you can
start exploring your creativity today so
make sure you guys check the link in the
description having said that let's get
back into our video on dr manhattan so
after that crazy experiment that turned
john into dr manhattan he goes and works
for the us government and he actually
starts calling himself dr manhattan
which is a nod to the manhattan project
which developed the first atomic bomb
but dr manhattan proves to be invaluable
to the us during the cold war and his
presence in vietnam gives the americans
a swift victory in the conflict as
opposed to the real world we basically
just went running with our tail between
our legs but he's also responsible for
multiple technological advances
including allowing the us to transition
from gas-powered engines to electric
however other countries see dr manhattan
as a threat and begin to build up their
nuclear arsenals in response now dr
manhattan would also join the group
known as the crimebusters a group of
costumed heroes including laurie
jaspezik the silk specter who dr
manhattan ends up dating now after
allegations that exposure to dr
manhattan caused former friends and
co-workers including his ex-girlfriend
janie to basically develop cancer john
leaves earth and goes to mars now
there's other reasons for that too
because basically john is just tired of
humanity and is ready to just leave the
earth and go somewhere else he is very
much he's very misanthropic in that way
when you think about it but the soviet
union capitalizes on his absence and
invades afghanistan which brings the
earth to the brink of nuclear war which
threatens the existence of mankind now
initially he has no interest in helping
mankind because he sees the end of
humanity as just a really really good
thing but silk specter convinces him to
return to earth where he finds out the
whole cancer thing was a lie made up by
his former teammate azamandis who has
become a revered public figure but who
has killed a lot of people to try to
avoid world war 3 which he successfully
does and honestly i can't say that it
was a bad thing i mean sure is it sad
but it's time for another episode of yes
but maybe yes
yes it's sad that he killed a lot of
people yes it's sad those people died
but maybe
maybe it was worth it to avoid a third
world war that would have involved the
end of mankind so having said that
rather than punish azamandius for
killing half of new york city dr
manhattan vaporizes another former
teammate rorschach who threatens to
reveal the truth about ozymandias
because manhattan believes revealing the
truth would actually lead to more
conflict following this dr manhattan
leaves earth to find a less complicated
like galaxy or universe or what have you
and that was the last time we ever saw
him or it would be if alan moore had
gotten his way but we'll come back to
that in a minute now first we need to go
over dr manhattan's powers and the thing
that makes him so powerful is his
ability to manipulate matter at a
sub-atomic level which effectively means
that he can do anything he wants he can
alter his size to massive heights and
can create a seemingly limitless number
of copies of himself each of which can
function independently of one another at
the same time so he can be pretty much
everywhere at once he can teleport
himself and others at will possesses
telekinesis and as we alluded to earlier
can disintegrate others with a mere
thought although he is not technically
omniscient he is able to perceive his
own past present and future
simultaneously now dr manhattan has made
the claim that he can sense tachyons
which are hypothetical particles that
move faster than the speed of light and
he has hypothesized that he has the
ability to create human life should he
desire to do that now as i said earlier
if alan moore had his way we would never
have seen doc manhattan again after the
events of the 12 issue watchmen series
but because of the terms of his contract
with dc they actually own the characters
and can use them in other books if they
want now for over 25 years dc honored
alan moore's wishes and didn't publish
any books using the watchmen characters
but that changed in 2012 when they
released a series of prequel comics
called before watchmen which explain the
origins of most of the characters and
we've already talked about the stuff
that it added to dr manhattan's origin
while before watchmen was controversial
since alan moore had nothing to do with
writing the stories and when i say
controversial i mean there were some
grumblings in 2016 dc made the even more
controversial decision which again more
grumblings to bring the watchman
characters into the main dc universe
with their rebirth initiative this
should come as no surprise to anybody
with dc doing this because as dc has
routinely brought characters from other
universes into the dc universe proper
now they brought in trout and characters
that we talked about earlier and after
they merged the vertigo wild storm and
milestone universes with the dc universe
as well it was only a matter of time
before they did the same with the
watchmen and that's important to our
discussion of dr manhattan because the
introduction of the watchmen into the dc
universe was really just a way to see dr
manhattan fight dc superheroes so what
we find out is that it was actually dr
manhattan that was responsible for the
reboot of the dc universe that occurred
with the launch of the new 52 when he
became aware of the dc universe dr
manhattan tried to correct the dc
timeline to avoid a potential third
world war so he orchestrated the
flashpoint event that would see barry
allen merge the dc wild storm and
vertigo universes and reboot the entire
dc universe now dr manhattan was also
responsible for trapping wally west in
the speed force along with several other
flash characters that had been seemingly
erased from existence in the new 52
relaunch but manhattan alters the dc
universe in other ways as well like
setting up a meeting between bruce wayne
and his father thomas wayne from the
flashpoint universe and saving jorel
from death following the destruction of
the planet krypton now both of these
were attempts to try and get the fathers
of dc's two most prominent heroes to
convince their sons to give up the
mantles and stop saving people but
neither of them worked we also end up
hearing from some really powerful dc
characters that have encountered docked
manhattan and relate how powerful he is
such as the reverse flash eobard font
who likens manhattan to god which was
just an amazing moment just in the
button you guys remember that like when
flashpoint like takes off like i think
what does he grabs a button whatever it
is he ends up taking off he encounters
dr manhattan off of like off panel he
comes back and he's like god i saw god
and then just disintegrates just dies
and it's just like wow like when that
story came out it was mind-blowing when
it happened of course the same thing
also happens with mr mixolyn who is it's
mr mitchell pittlick i just don't feel
like pronouncing his name because it's
just more of a pain in the ass and it's
worth but he's an extremely powerful
reality warper in his own right and
admits that his power pales in
comparison to that of dr manhattan now
everything comes to a head during the
doomsday clock event which is where we
finally get to see dr manhattan take on
the dc universe and i'm not even going
to begin to explain the events of
doomsday clock here because that would
take forever and i've already covered it
in a series of videos that you can just
go back and watch but one of the big
moments is when almost every superhero
in the dc universe minus superman batman
and wonder woman confront dr manhattan
on mars and this group includes martian
manhunter multiple green lanterns
captain adam the flash shazam just a ton
of heavy hitters and they're all utterly
powerless to do anything to docker
manhattan even when captain adams
seemingly vaporizes manhattan he
reappears seconds later and then
incapacitates the whole group now
unfortunately we don't get a showdown
between dr manhattan and superman
because man hadn't observed superman's
heroism and is inspired to undo a lot of
the changes that he made in reality in
creating the new 52 universe before
returning to his home universe and
giving his earth all his energy in order
to restore it erasing himself from
existence in the process you heard that
right ladies and gentlemen the entirety
of doomsday clock was well hopefully i i
don't remember if jeff john said that
superman and dr manhattan were going to
fight i think he said they weren't but i
think as the fan base we just decided
they would and then we just got mad when
they didn't
even though we were told they wouldn't
but i really did want to see a fight
between dr manhattan and superman even
though i know full well superman
wouldn't win it still would have been
cool but now that we've covered dr
manhattan and honestly we couldn't have
a list of beyond omega level characters
that didn't include him we now have the
role he played in the creation of the dc
universe as we know it but let me know
what you guys think why did you enjoy
seeing dr manhattan the dc universe or
should dc have just left him alone like
ellen moore wanted as always make sure
you guys leave a comment down below with
characters that you want to see and i
will catch you all later
peace